[Music]
well today's pointers from a
pediatrician segment is focusing on
rsv and to explain a little bit more
about that is dr
carrie weshinger the owner and medical
director of siena pediatrics
who joins us once again thank you so
much doctor for talking to us
so let's start off what is rsv and what
infections does it cause
yes so rsv is respiratory sensational
virus
it's a very common virus that most of
the children get by
two years of age yes all right doctor so
is it normal to be seeing these cases
right now
so no it's highly atypical we usually
see these viruses
in late fall early winter
and so in june we might have a couple
sporadic cases but this is actually
rather high volumes for this time of
year
okay i'm sure a question that many
parents are probably asking is how is it
transmitted
and who is there's basically
you can cough sneeze in someone's face
so we've been protected for the last
15 months because we've been wearing our
masks the other way is to actually get
it by touching
surfaces and being in direct contact
with it
so with all of us learning not to touch
our eyes and our nose
uh and better we've actually minimized
the risk as well
as we get out there or 100 open um
this virus decided to make a comeback in
summer
that's why it's always good to make sure
that everyone washes their hands and
carry that uh
that hand sanitizer and what kind of
testing and treatments if any can
doctors offer
so we have a rapid test already for
several years uh rapid rc tests that
most pediatricians can do in our office
very simple takes five to ten minutes to
do um
there's really no uh actual vaccine at
this point they're
supposedly working on that but we do not
have it yet
um the one thing i do want to mention is
the risk factors
for our city include children that are
premature below 34 weeks of age
when they're born and kids with casual
heart
and lung diseases they can get
a special kind of uh vaccine if you want
to call it
a monoclonal antibody called synergist
so you would have to talk to your
pediatrician
about that um and then we naturally
refer to the
facilities that are doing that too
awesome well dr kerry thank you so much
for talking to us
uh today we appreciate it as always and
we'll be talking to you very soon
thank you very much